hallo herzlich willkommen in SIS Welt
und herzlich willkommen im sellicon
Valley heute ist für uns ein richtig
besonderer Tag denn wir haben heute ganz
viele Gäste eingeladen wir haben
Familien und Kinder da vom Bundesverband
kinderhospit der Bundesverband
kinderusbeats engagiert sich für
Familien deren Kinder unheilbar krank
sind und davon gibt's leider in
Deutschland über 50.000 und es ist eine
unfassbar große Zahl und es sind Kinder
die praktisch wachsen werden aber auch
diese Kinder und diese Familien die
einen solchen Schicksalsschlag erlebt
haben sollen einfach ein schönes Leben
haben sollen schöne Momente genießen und
ich bin schon seit einigen Jahren Patin
des Bundesverbandes kinderhospit jedes
Jahr findet z.B auch im Europapark immer
ein ganz ganz besonderer Tag statt der
Europapark lädt alle ein und macht immer
einen wunderschönen Tag dort den könnt
ihr euch gerne auch schon mal vormerken
auch der Europapark ist heute da die
Euromaus ist nämlich da der
und die miriam ist da vom Europa Park
und wir werden heute hier einen richtig
schönen Tag mit den Kindern Familien und
Geschwisterkindern verbringen denn wir
haben in selicon Valley eingeladen zum
gemeinsamen Backen zum gemeinsamen Spaß
haben Eisessen denn es ist wirklich
furchtbar warm heute wir werden hier
grillen und einfach eine schöne Zeit
verbringen also kommt mit und schaut
euch einfach mal an was wir hier heute
[Musik]
machen
ein
Z herzlich willkommen bei uns in SIS
Welt und im sicon Valley schön dass Ihr
alle da seid ich freue mich riesig euch
alle kennenzulernen und wir freuen uns
alle drauf ein schönen Tag mit Euch zu
verbringen ja die erste große
Überraschung wir haben ed da
ist extra aus Rust angereist heute an
diesem warmen Tag und mit könnt ihr
natürlich gerne Fotos machen vielleicht
machen wir noch eine kleine Tanzeinlage
zusammen oder wir verbringen auf jeden
Fall eine schöne Zeit zusammen und
deswegen würden wir direkt am Anfang
gerne einfach ein richtig schönes großes
Leinwandbild mit euch machen wo sich
jeder drauf verewigen kann mit seinen
Händen mit Farben die ihr euch selber
aussuchen dürft und das würden wir dann
gerne euch schenken dass ihr das mit
nehmen könnt und habt dann immer eine
Erinnerung an den schönen Tag ganz am
Ende gibt's ein großes Geschenk für euch
eine große Geschenktüte für jeden
einzelnen die dürft ihr euch dann gerne
mitnehmen und wenn ihr ganz viel Lust
habt hier haben wir auch eine Fotobox
aufgebaut das heißt wenn ihr coole Fotos
machen wollt wir haben auch Kostüme
Verkleidung und alles mit dabei ich
komme da auch gerne immer mal dazu
können wir lustige Bilder machen die
sind zum sofort ausdrucken und dann
könnt ihr die auch alle mitnehmen ich
nehme euch jetzt mal mit und zeig euch
was wir heute für schne haben
also hier richtig schön kann sich jeder
mit seinem handabuck drauf verewigen und
das Bild schenken wir dann einfach dem
Bundesverband kinderus einfach als
schöne Erinnerung für den heutigen
[Musik]
Tag ich haben eine richtig schöne
Schminkstation da kann sich jeder
schminken lassen einfach mit
Kinderschminke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schau mal die sind für dich wer möchte
noch
mitbacken dürft euch auch gerne drum
rumstellen alles
gut
[Musik]
und wenn Ihr fertig seid dann dürft ihr
auch gerne an in unser Fotostudio gell
dann dürft ihr sogar Fotos schießen
[Musik]
davon
ich hoffe die schmecken euch genauso gut
wie mir gebe ich einfach der Mama
mit richtig toll geworden ja ich finde
die solltest du auf jeden Fall
fotografieren lassen okay solche Profi
Cupcakes soll ich mit dir mal zum
Fotostudio gehen komm mal
[Applaus]
mit ja so eine Hilfe in der Küche könnte
ich auch gebrauchen
ja manchmal kommen meine Kinder nämlich
gar nicht mehr zum helfen die wollen nur
noch
naschen schön oder guck mal was für
tolle Bilder ihr da machen könnt gefällt
dir so du hast du hast zwei gemacht ja
zwei sogar wel findest du am schönsten
den oder
den ja ich könnte mich da auch nicht
entscheiden
[Musik]
dann mach du mal schön deine Fotos ich
komme gleich noch mal zum Schauen okay
bin richtig
gespannt
[Musik]
du
dari ist bisschen anders ist ein
Nack ein chinesischer schopfund
chinesischer schopfund dann hat schon
mal nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ne in deren Klasse bist
du
cool ganz schön anstrengend oder die
Schule
macht Spaß ja das ist schön man lernt ja
auch immer was fürs
[Musik]
Leben darf ich mit euch
kuscheln süße Maus
[Musik]
gell
jetzt die Kul Station Fotobox ich komme
jetzt einmal bei euch mit dazu
[Applaus]
okay 4 3 2
und gefällt dir ja jetzt schön
lachen natürlich eine Feier ohne hitch
candyb
geh natürlich gibt eine
HCH sehr
gemein ja leider kann man da nicht mehr
aufen voll
ja
und für Abkühlung ist hier natürlich
auch gesorgt wir nämlich für alle und
schön Wasser
[Musik]
undrke das da hier ist von von als aus
Mannheim ist der türkische brutzlerind h
sind
hammerge egessen aber ich will noch mal
eine ja und für uns war hier das Thema
Inklusion natürlich auch ganz wichtig
deswegen haben wir bei uns drüben im
studiog Gebäude auch schon einen
Fahrstuhl den haben wir damals eingebaut
weil wir wussten meine Eltern ziehen
irgendwann mit ein müssen wir mal
schauen ob sie irgendwann mit einziehen
hier im zweiten Gebäude hatten wir nicht
von Anfang an dran gedacht und dann
haben wir aber den Michael kennengelernt
der kam hier einfach auf die Baustelle
und hat gesagt halt stopp habt ihr mal
vielleicht dran gedacht an
rollstulfahrer an Menschen die
vielleicht eine Beeinträchtigung beim
Gehen haben denn ihr habt ja zwei
Stockwerk
jetzt haben wir hier herolift eingebaut
und zwar einmal hier draußen beim
Grillplatz denn wir wollten auch bei
egal welcher Feier natürlich dass jeder
hier auch auf den Grillplatz kann das
heißt hier draußen haben wir diesen
fahrstuhllift direkt an der Treppe wo
man praktisch einfach mit dem Rollstuhl
dran kann und wirklich hochfahren kann
so dass wirklich jeder überall in jedes
Gebäude kommt ja und so ist bei uns
kommt jeder überall auch mit dem
Rollstuhl hin und ich muss sagen wir
hatten ja auch schon Teammitglieder die
im Rollstuhl sitzen und deswegen ist es
einfach wichtig weil so alle überall
hinkommen und jeder einfach alles machen
kann und keiner ausgeschlossen wird
wünschte ich dass es überall so wäre an
jedem Bahnhof an jedem Bus überall aber
es leider noch nicht überall so aber wer
weiß siehst du er kam hier auf die Idee
und hat gesagt s ihr braucht noch einen
Lift ja und der heißt wie Held also Hero
heißt nur mit i geschrieben
hero
[Musik]
ja will auch da
werden und was ist deine besondere
Fähigkeit Instagram cool aber du hast
noch kein Account oderch nicht ne
bisschen zu
früh also du muss mir dann die Frage
beantworten ob ich ins da bin ich weiß
es nicht ja du bist da ja okay wenn du
das sagst wird es schon so stimmen ne
okay aber ich fühle mich gar nicht wie
einer der
Reporter geht dir mir geht's gut wie
geht's dir
gut mein Lieblingskuchen ist alles was
mit Streuseln ist und ich habe für heute
auch ja Streuselkuchen und ich habe
heute soaruselkuchen Backen den gibt's
da unten falls du probieren willst
darfst du gerne
probieren lieber nicht vertraust du
nicht meinen Backkünsten oder magst du
keine
streuseel ach du bist der Fleischesser
okay dann haben wir für dich
grillwüstchen da wenn du
willst ja kannst bestimmt mal Reporter
werden es war ein sehr angenehmes
Interview mit dir
[Musik]
danke
danke dass du da warst war richtig schön
mit dir
danke schön dass du da bist
[Musik]
Tobi jetzt ist unser Tag hier leider
schon zu Ende die ersten Gäste sind
schon weg die anderen gehen jetzt gleich
muss sagen der Abschied ist auch immer
ganz im emotional aber ich weiß dass
viele Kinder das heißt viele ich weiß
dass alle Kinder und alle Eltern hier
heute einen richtig schönen Tag hatten
und auch wenn es uns nicht immer ganz
leicht gefallen ist immer zu lächeln
weil man dann doch irgendwie so ein
bisschen bedrückt ist und einfach es
einem einfach leid tut dass es Menschen
gibt denen es nicht so gut geht was für
uns alle und auch für mein Team ein
richtig richtig schöner Tag ich muss
sagen ich werde heute Abend ganz
glücklich ins Bett fallen und mir noch
mal die Bilder und Videos anschauen von
heute ich freue mich schon auf das
nächste Treffen spätestens am 15 Oktober
im Europapark da ist nämlich wieder der
bundeshospiztag dort und der Europapark
lädt uns alle ein alle Familien alle
Kinder es ist richtig schön danke alle
aus meinem Team dass ihr da wart dass
ihr hier heute geholfen habt und danke
an alle Gäste die dabei waren und ich
hoffe wenn ihr zu Hause euch dieses
Video anschaut dass ihr einfach noch mal
den schönen Tag hier Review passieren
lassen könnt bis zum nächsten
Mal
[Musik]